pato ne s'inquiète pas
oui je m'en fous mais ça je m'en fous
m'en fous
réponse est un acteur rejeté l'idée de
ne pas toucher
aux formations et lutte incendie
les pompiers vous avez des extincteurs
vous ici on fait une petite
démonstration un petit cours théoriques
pratiques pour bien savoir utiliser
l'extincteur donc on tire la bobinette
l extincteur chirat
comme ça on est coupé et après on se met
face au foyer
sur le foyer comme ça
voilà up et voyez ça
[Applaudissements]
ça mais des trucs un peu partout on
tient la cheville est saisie non way for
abba des dents on a le temps de chrome
est avec vous allez-y
ben justement c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça qu'on est là sur le gâteau
maintenant lui prendre rendez-vous et
puis robin est ce que le feu prend
rendez vous monsieur hop on attend que
ça prenne un peu
allez-y avant tout on crie au feu
alors faut remettre la boue pis parce
que oui et sa part n'importe comment
voilà
le pardon au maire
il faut remettre la vous paierez n'avait
pas mis la goupille
voilà maintenant vous le savez on vous a
tout appris
vous me réglez maintenant
le court
construit mais moi je n'ai pas besoin de
payer son nom mais vous rigolez ou quoi
la non attendez vous prenez une
formation professionnelle attendait que
le formation professionnelle 3 veut ça a
duré 30 secondes pour enlever le truc la
goupille et puis appuyer un coup c'est
le truc là eh ben ouais mais vous de
saveur non moi je ne ferais que rien du
tout bon bah je suis juste braque ou
alors
juste boire un coup
moussa balla chez moi bah oui mais faut
pas rigoler non plus on va bien fait du
bien à bertrand avec le rendre en chine
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi
je suis sûr que j'étais sapeur pompier
ou
[Musique]